Oh, my God.
Don’t look like no plane.
Don't look like no helicopter.
What the [bleep] is it?
UFO sightings burst into the news in 1947.
These sightings have continued
ever since.
The Air Force made an effort to
clear the air about the phenomenon.
There's nothing to hide at all.
I was stunned that we didn't
have the integrity to pursue this.
The U.S.
government closed its study of UFO’s
and so the work fell
into the hands of civilian groups.
The UFO reports not only
exist, but persist.
I mean, it's a definite UFO.
The government owes it to this country
to investigate sightings
of extraordinary objects.
We cover the whole entire sky.
People want to know, is this otherworldly?
This could be one of the biggest events in
all of human history.